[Musique]
je voudrais vous montrer deux petites
choses hier soir nous sommes allés à
versailles et oui on essaye d'aller à
versailles avec tout public alors
c'était pas le même public à la qui
était déjà la guerre apparemment ils
sont tous cas ce qu'à versailles merci à
et et les chéris voilà c'était mon
anniversaire hier on voudrait vous
montrer un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
et ce soir d'ailleurs à 21h vous aurez
les pépites et pepita pépito spécial
maxime guennic et 10 à la soirée
versaillais ce moment regardez c'est et
il est regardé
hureau ababa avait prévu les choses en
grand pour sa ré soit d'anniversaire
trois bus pour transporter ses 150
convives survoltée vous aimez les
merguez vous allez tu fais la soirée
bien lieu pour rêver toute l'année à
france soir et rime forcément avec
musique
[Applaudissements]
mais c'était sans compter sur les
caprices de notre roi n'a pas gras durs
la pallice quart
[Musique]
les faux
[Applaudissements]
et pour couronner le tout une pièce
montée de tarbes a depuis son apparition
les convives en europe y plein les yeux
merci beaucoup c'est super nanny merci
mec en or
[Applaudissements]
mais vous savez le franchement et
j'aurais voulu tous vous amener tous
ceux qui nous regardent les chéris
malheureusement bon on fera ce qui
reviennent sont chaque année on fera des
trucs de ouf et vous le savez on prépare
le tour de france pour début janvier on
va venir vous voir et on va vous faire
des cadeaux de malades j'irai dans toute
la france pour faire des cadeaux parce
qu'on vous aime très très fort les
chéris merci à yamaha team également été
là pendant la soirée
regardez à qui me regardent et sait pas
on se retrouve actuellement
l'anniversaire de sylvain qui m'invitait
mais je suis pas invité à rester ainsi
donc c'est pas grave du coup je vais
faire chier les gens j'adore tranquille
classe génial chic et cher pays
il est refait ya que des tribuns c'est
pas très très très très très très bien
ils ont des superlatifs chelou ici mais
bon c'est vraiment très très très très
très bien qui m'appelait la vienne jeudi
que justement c'est pas parce qu'ils
m'appellent la vieille que les méchants
n'allait pas si bien que ça ait un
monsieur chelou au fond ce fameux pas vu
je crois qu'il est un peu le som d'être
ici mais bon il se débrouille bien
je suis très content on va parler à la
rousseau apparemment la venue ce soir
mais gentille petite chanson je sais pas
quoi chanter ou bambou outre youtube et
que les paroles mais c'était ça c'était
ça mais vous viendrez vraiment dire vous
venez habillés pareil a rejoint oui ce
sera plus pratique mais selon elle sera
peut-être en sip super à l'aise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]